hey what's going on is Bill bird it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast
just check it in on you
sorry that's right I'm just checking in
you have a special guest to I don't know
if you ever heard that intro before we
have Bret Ernst from the you're on the
list podcast just added to the all
things comedy Network he's got a ton of
[ __ ] here he also has a stand-up special
hilarious special principal's office
that you can watch for free free free at
Bret comedy cambiar et comedy calm you
can watch it for free God knows all you
[ __ ] Millennials love that you don't
have pay for [ __ ] and he's in the new
Karate Kid Cobra Kai on YouTube red tell
me about that that's a wrap my shoes
yeah Wow May 2nd yeah it was pretty cool
man yeah the guys I actually had him on
the podcast yesterday that executive
produced Hot Tub Time Machine they did a
Harold & Kumar and they're doing this
too and they're doing this off so do you
know it's gonna be quality yeah it's
pretty cool man and and basically it
just picks up with Johnny and uh and
Daniel when they're 15 yeah Daniel
Daniel runs a car dealership in the
valley and Johnny's just down on his
luck I'm [ __ ] in now do they have the
what was the name of the actor who
played the Billy Zabka William Zabka
is he unit yeah he's in it [ __ ] yeah
Johnny's in it and it's it's pretty cool
because it's uh they're given that
they're screening the first two episodes
in theaters like across the country but
like select theaters but it just got
into Tribeca which to do this whole
thing you know sometimes and they reboot
something I'm just like why
I'll just because that's kind of weird I
thought they kind of completed it you
know there's some instances where they
literally have to bring characters back
from the dead yeah we don't have any CGI
miyagi and yeah yeah but this one here
what I like is they're not like hiding
the time that went by and that okay
picks them up they're in their 50s and I
think that's a really
you know interesting thing just as far
as being finally in a writers room after
all these years on a show that I do is
is just getting to write to that and you
get to fill in all of this cool like
backstory there isn't happening you
learn more about Johnny like nobody ever
really touched on you know because
people forget he was still a kid in high
school you know what I mean but now I'm
you learn a little bit more about him
you know and then I play actually day I
don't want you to give anything away but
he was he was a kid of divorce right
yeah his dad wasn't around that you know
which was perfect cuz well that
eliminated why wouldn't your dad just
teach you how to fight I got rid of that
I mean he had this what 16 17 year old
kid with this you know horrible sense a
you know that was so impression Ilan
them but it's pretty cool oh I'm talking
I don't know the character's name I
thought you were talking about the cry
Ralph Macchio it's not named Johnny
Johnny Johnny Johnny is a bad well I
mean it's pretty and I think dick ative
I guess at that time where you know I
was a latchkey kid Ryan go everybody had
single moms and yeah well Daniels you
know both keep em both my parents worked
so we all had we all had keys and I
remember had all the names of the kids
right by the door and we would all kept
our keys and then yeah you'd come home
and whoever was the oldest was running
[ __ ] yeah and could tell you know just
had total [ __ ] authority could tell
you to go to bed like my older brother
would tell me to go to bed and I had to
do it if I didn't he'd beat the [ __ ] out
of me yeah you're like you're only a
year older than me I started fighting
back so then what he understood was like
alright I'll keep him under my wing and
now I got a four year buffer between the
next kid and then that's when his power
was solidified and I sold out I sold out
all my younger siblings just so I could
stay up and watch [ __ ] deputy dawg
that was the middleman but my older
brother had all the authority you I
would come home and you know he was like
the man of the house at 12
oh yeah and i woved nine ten I was sick
I was four years old Oh eight yeah he
keep was three or five five so yeah so
yeah and that lasted pretty much most of
my what I taught you about power
can corrupt somebody how most people
can't handle it alright so now I'm
really fascinating about this so Johnny
is the Cobra Kai guy I'm sorry well you
know it but you're both you're right on
both ends
I do think Johnny's father wasn't around
either but Daniel yeah Daniel had to
learn from the [ __ ] maintenance
father who better than the guy that
fixes the sink I think this is that's a
really brilliant way to go and I this
this seems like a cool YouTube thing
because I feel if this was on a more
major network they would be like yeah
but who are we gonna root for and blah
blah blah like let's let's stab it based
around the Ralph Macchio character well
apparently I mean there was a lot of you
know there was a lot of offers for this
and I think you know then the Netflix of
the world maybe even including Netflix
that they kind of bid on it and YouTube
red got got you know they got the nod so
big they well they were telling us
because I was asking them yesterday on
the podcast
the producers I'm like you know through
the process and everything and they said
they want you to read it and just
figured alright this would be like the
practice pitch and but as as it late you
know as they sat on it some more and saw
the interest and what they were gonna be
able to do and it just became more
appealing and they want with I'm a big
believer in that I'm a big believer and
not taking the money if somebody else
will give you more yeah what you want to
do cuz then he goes down swinging with
what you you want to do and I also get
you'll get more control you get more of
I saw this great thing one time this
heavy metal band that never made it and
it just I forget with anyone the
documentary was but it just took them
through their whole career and how they
just stayed together and stayed together
and still was that anvil him though this
guy knows everything he's like Google oh
thank you Aaron in the photo Aaron in
the corner um anvil and this guy's he
just said this thing he said at the end
of the day he goes you're better to own
a hundred percent of something and sell
20,000 copies then to own nothing and
sell 20 million like that's how bad you
get [ __ ] with like all of the Lois's
and
that type of [ __ ] that was my thought
process and giving a special away for
free is that you know I put my own money
into it and you know it wasn't cheap I
mean for me at least you know as a comic
you write it you're always check to
check so basically like I think my next
special I'll try and shop it but excuse
me well don't ever give up ownership
know why well the thing for me was that
this was kind of a personal thing for me
like it's kind of like a one-man show in
a stand-up format but I only had one eye
only enough money for one take I did it
in a colony theater in Burbank but the
concept was basically I want to own it
because I found it dare you well all my
other business how dare you well the
thing that kinda I should be worried
about exposure we're gonna pay you an
exposure well the thing is do is that
like all the stuff that I did before on
Comedy Central show I didn't own any of
it I wasn't even able to share it you
know what I mean on Facebook so I
released it for free at Bret comedy calm
and you could go there but the thing is
you could just watch it you don't have
to I mean you can give me your email if
you want if you want to donate or I mean
or own it download it for $5 or buy a
t-shirt you get to download if you want
to but you don't have to do anything I
just want you to watch it and if you
like it you like it if you don't put
your head on the desk move on it's fun
it's [ __ ] free I remember early on I
had a uh I made a CD I have stand-up CD
that's how long I've been like you know
way back in the day and I you know put
all my money up pay to have it recorded
edited the thing the thing was done and
then these big guys came around and they
were going to get it into stores
this is 2006 right before every virgin
closed and I was such an old-school guy
was like I want my CD in a record store
you know and in with with the power of
these guys he'll get me under the
display towards the front of the store
right and but I knew enough that I
wanted to retain ownership and they just
kept they kept trying to get to own it
and it was like I don't need you to own
it it's done mm-hmm I don't need any
money on this thing I just I just need
you to distribute it and this guy goes
to me he goes well ownership shouldn't
be that big
deal to you which it because what you
should be concerned about his exposure
so I said to him I go alright fair
enough but if ownership shouldn't be
that bit much of a big deal for me why
is it such a big deal for you and my
manager was in the room and he goes
great [ __ ] question and this guy
stammered for about 15 seconds and then
basically said well you know we got in
business with these other comics to make
CDs and their CDs bombed and we have to
make up the money it's just like well
it's it's not my fault that you got into
business with those [ __ ] guys and the
greatest thing I ever did was retain
ownership I ended up getting in business
with somebody else and that was like you
know hey you get 60% we get 40% I'm like
hey that sounds like a good deal and
then all the expenses come out of my end
yeah and they get they get 40 off the
gross I got 60 off the net and end up
making more money than I did it to this
day they try to tell me that that was a
good deal it's like dude this thing came
it's like week you always think like
we're getting in business together to
make money off them and that's not how
they do it it was like we're getting and
work yeah they're gonna [ __ ] the people
and you and all the money's gonna go to
them my favourite thing is I get in
business with somebody else and all the
money goes to them and then when I get
my cut their names on my check and it's
just like so how the [ __ ] do I know what
came in and then if you audit them then
you get labeled as difficult to work
yeah it's like difficult to work with it
difficult to steal from and that like I
and one of these deals I had it was like
it was one of the DVD companies if I was
to audit them and they were off less
than like eight percent then I had to
pay for the audit and it's like what you
just gave them a license to steal seven
and a half percent yeah and it's just
like I'm telling you the number one
commandment of the Ten Commandments
that's [ __ ] that's that's broken maybe
it's lying but what I've seen is
stealing like all of these [ __ ]
idiots who were out there who are
stealing on the illegal side of stealing
selling drugs I mean anybody who's in
the mob who was smart eventually went
legit so you could steal on the legal
side then you didn't have to hide your
[ __ ] money and you could drive down
the street you [ __ ] Bentley well I've
never look I love our business I love
the people in our business
you know but there's a good amount of
them that are just [ __ ] garbage and I
don't even know if that garbage is just
the weight though it's like the way it
was set up well when you fillet it was
set up you figures coli in the game like
when you first come in this is why I
love this era of comedy and and where
we're at especially with the digital and
the in the internet and stuff like I
always say I only need one percent of
America to like me and I'm good that's
it yeah that's it you know even if even
if I can say a joke onstage you know in
a room full of [ __ ] adults and
somehow he's good Oh
somebody just said somebody just sent me
this for this [ __ ] article somebody
just sent me this article like this I
can't I can't even [ __ ] read this but
there are but every guy checks himself a
little New York comedy clubs adjust to
me too and it's just like this is just
like such like you didn't even stick
your head in the comedy clubs I'm seeing
the opposite yeah this like this
backlash and there's this time now to be
more irreverent than ever because you
know not all feminists are bad but these
extreme ones like what they're doing now
with these articles is like the way we
left Vietnam where we go eh we won and
they're leaving that's what they're
saying like I'm finding myself I'm
saying [ __ ] on stage now I never would
have gone that far but it's just like
because you have to you would you I mean
we're all could you would have to agree
that we're contrarians by nature yeah
which would be funny we disagree but I'm
just saying no no no I don't you totally
loved it overnight no um but even some
of the women are going the other way too
like I've been noticed a lot of common
female comics doing jokes you know where
they wish you know like in other words
now they're now they're not getting any
action you know and right and but it's
just what becomes inevitable we're just
one thing just gets it get becomes
exhausted like it's all been said we get
it and then it's just like how many
times can you keep reiterating the same
point I really believe that if comics
you know we're such a great think tank
because we really don't I mean real good
comics you know
because you could sit around you have no
real skin in the game it's more about
the joke or the perceptive or anytime
anybody tries to [ __ ] do that thing
where they go like you know like when
they try to put too much weight on a
joke
I always just get now dude no it's just
what I always say to them like if they
sit there like what you're saying does
influence even blah blah I just say to
them I say look are you homophobic and
they of course say no I go okay enduring
a 60 minute set that I do what Joe could
I tell that would then make you
homophobic mm-hmm how could I undo
everything that you were taught in 60
what how many how many of those jokes
what I have to do so my point of that is
is is people come in I'm so sick of
talking about this to people come in
okay they're there they're adults their
brains are fully formed and they have
their ideas the amount of times I say
[ __ ] and it's just like people take it a
completely different way is one of the
cool things about like somebody listen
to music comedy or anything it's it goes
into your brain and your experience and
how you interpret it but like it's not
my responsibility to babysit you and if
you take it in some really bad [ __ ]
way you walked in with that [ __ ] mm-hmm
cuz if I had the power to undo your 26
years of experience with a couple of
[ __ ] jokes then stand-up comedy would
not be legal think they wouldn't let a
[ __ ] [ __ ] like me go onstage going
hey I haven't read about [ __ ] you know
what I think about this area I mean I
always not disarm myself but I always I
am a jerk-off I know I'm a jerk-off I'm
not I'm not like you know me both you
know what I mean like I don't yeah I
don't take myself serious I have the
high school transcript to prove it dude
you're not as dumb as you say oh yeah I
am I am I I'm good it's just you're
watching the one thing that I'm good at
which is basically acting like a [ __ ]
idiot but if you got me on and I could
do like like basic jobs you know what I
mean like I was a [ __ ] like workhorse
if you told me to go over there and pick
up all those boxes and stick them over
there I would [ __ ] crush that but if
you wanted me to come up with a machine
that could [ __ ] and make the easier to
do that yeah I'm out I'm like
[ __ ] lunch-pail luiz moura
I would what makes me laugh too is that
even the comics that take themselves so
seriously in a sense is like do we like
you know that the acts that game that we
were on take themselves seriously hacks
think they're [ __ ] change in the
world because they're too [ __ ] well
realize they stink here I realized so I
was on a plane that we had a emergency
land okay and I was always fun some do
try to kill next to them started choking
on [ __ ] like we were literally five
minutes in the air and and I'm like [ __ ]
cuz I was gonna miss my gig that night
you know that's all I care about
oh we not crashing no well why are we
going I got I got to make my gig you
know he tried to kill the game starts
choking - dude so then the guy would
preceded it like I was all the way in
the back I think the guy just flipped on
him it was like some dude that was I'm
gonna go with the armrest huh there's an
RFID okay so anyways long story boring
the guy's obviously playing it up now
that he you know so they start now else
in the back don't know what's going on
okay so the stewardess runs back said we
do is there anybody here in the medical
profession you know in a medical field a
couple people get up I see a guy that
was a cop get up a guy that was a
fireman she should have said attention
everyone there's nothing wrong with the
plane well they made that they say they
came back it came back to us I mean this
is after they were asking for it for
everybody's I would've been the back
half [ __ ] is a cop gonna flight a plane
but the point being is that they said
all these people started getting up and
that's when you realize that your job is
so [ __ ] useless oh yeah it's like in
any I'm not even I just needed watch and
mate you know unless they're like hey
can you come up and do five minutes to
cheer everybody further than that all
these people have a real purpose and I'm
not saying we don't but at you know if
you're doing the modules hierarchy thing
comics are not like we're like junk food
absolutely you know what I mean it's
just a comfort food kind of [ __ ]
that's McDonald it's not nutrition yes
so instead of
hello so you're gonna be hungry again
for knowledge
ten minutes after watching my act yeah
like if you're if you're learning from
me that's there's some off its sad my
friend if anybody ever said that to me I
beg oh no no sorry point of towards a
library or something like all these
comics think they're Carlin but and I
don't think there's a lot of that though
I thought there's a lot of political
it's probably going to say especially in
like the open mikes were and even
there's a couple younger comics that
we're talking to me that they coined a
term called clapped er what is that like
these called an old laughing just make
up make a statement and everybody's like
yeah you know icicle that was the Oprah
you don't need to get a job laughter
well I think you know just going if
you're online all the time and like you
just you get stuck into that [ __ ]
swirl a rabbit hole of that [ __ ] where
it's just like you know when people just
start posting these this information
that you need to know it's like where
did you get this who the [ __ ] are you
and there's a couple two words I hate
the most on the is curating and
algorithm if I see that anywhere I just
[ __ ] I just because I gotta be honest
with you like even like as much as I
love Netflix and everything like that
it's like you watch one season of narcos
your whole [ __ ] thing is just now
going to be all drug dealers behind
memories of prisons you know San Quentin
the real you know the real [ __ ] and it's
just like you know you almost get
offended like you know this more to me
than just that so I watch you look at
like um when when I did my last special
when I went in and they showed me how
the algorithm worked I mean I always
[ __ ] blown away but like so maybe it
isn't their fault maybe I'm such a
[ __ ] [ __ ] that I watched too many
they're just like we gave up on this guy
let's just well I share one with my wife
and she's always like I watch cartoons
what he [ __ ] twelve you know I would
love them to bring back his Jonny Quest
Jonny Quest was alright I wasn't
I gotta be honest with you man wasn't a
big fan of that you know I love about
Jonny Quest if you fell off a cliff he
had died that blew my mind
he got shot you [ __ ] died like people
were dying yeah you used to Bugs Bunny
where everybody just came back yeah wily
coyote turned into a [ __ ] accordion
Gabe you look like well that didn't work
and then he comes back totally fine it
should've been in a [ __ ] wheelchair
let's get back to let's get by the way I
saw a meme talking about the Facebook
[ __ ] real quick I was dying laughing it
was a general it says uh well we can't
leave we bomb Syria let me go into
Facebook and see what the experts say
need to know what our next move is and
find out what all the experts say yeah
I'd be honest with you I don't
understand that whole part of the world
I the people that were fighting and all
that but I also know that I haven't read
up on it but I just look at it like the
people fighting don't have a plane or a
boat I just don't get how they're gonna
get us I know 9/11 happened but they
caught us with their pants down so all
you have to do is just what is Israel do
it really hasn't had a hijacking of a
plane and like I don't know how many you
do it in the front and then when they
watch the planes all night mhm so it's
not even a [ __ ] option and they're
sitting right in the middle of that
hornets nest over there and they're able
to survive it so I don't know I'm I hope
I'm just worried about us financially
just I feel like those these [ __ ]
jerk-offs they're dragging us into the
deep water here mm-hmm and you know the
in the hole there's more than one way to
skin a cat and it's just because you
know realistically why would you ever
try to fight us we could literally blow
up the whole [ __ ] thing with one push
of a button if we wanted to but I'm I
don't know maybe somebody over there is
good at math so is it better than I do
but I just sit this debt wakes me up at
night that's why I try to not to I try
to like keep all my [ __ ] I'm not good
with it so like any time I see is your
wife handle that stuff no no I do I am a
[ __ ] one-stop operation I handle the
whole [ __ ] thing
oh it's a couple days later and now I'm
doing the advertising old Billy sniffles
Oh Oh Billy sniffle got cold all right
me undies dudududu me undies me undies I
can't breathe out my nose to do through
me undies me undies I'm gonna use my
mouth that's how it goes mouth breathing
more run in the south shut the [ __ ] up
just close your mouth no one cares about
your ar-15 or the fact that trumps gonna
build a wall put on your undies sorry
look [ __ ] is it uh the undies the undies
you've heard me talk about me undies and
you know that I am a big believer in
their products I believe that when you
put them on they cover your privates
they're the perfect balance of
comfortable fit every month they have
new and exciting prints and they arrive
at your door in a fun bag the undies
uses lensing micro mode al modal and
their underwear
it's a sustainably sourced natural soft
fiber that starts with beech wood trees
and ends with you not giving a [ __ ] what
they do with it
your balls will feel great that's what
you need to know beyond the OREA clam me
undies adventurous prints and designs
are all limited editions and new
patterns are released every few weeks on
a rolling basis 100% satisfaction
guarantee beyond these guarantees you
will love to your undies or you'll get
your money's back me undies has a great
offer for my listeners anytime you
purchase me up here what the first time
purchase you get 20% off free shipping
this is gonna be too long to send via
phone the undies is so sure you'll love
their underwear they offer are hundreds
obsessed I should guarantee you don't
let the first pair you get a full refund
and you give your old underwear to some
Tweaker out front this is no brainer get
20% off your pair and the most of the
most comfortable undies you'll ever put
on to get your 20% off first pair free
shipping and hunt since that's that
guarantee go to me undies comm / /
that's me uneasy calm / bar
yeah I'm somehow I'm still an ass even I
even do dishes too
I just it's just [ __ ] I actually
enjoy doing dishes and cleaning up
because I'm a [ __ ] lunatic I can't
sit still I don't know how to you know
time I could [ __ ] relax as if I'm
smoking a cigar and I'm off from right
now let me ask you this question out of
the if you were to say you had one of
those the popular three that comedians
have the a DD check OCD don't have that
depression I had I didn't have the
chemical one I was just walking around
bummed out for a long time I didn't
realize it because I was always like
that
well there's depression so intelligence
you know like like in other words and
not saying you're intelligent but you
see all these patterns and you just see
like what the [ __ ] is wrong with people
like you know and it just gets to you
because that used to but I know how do I
know how to talk my way out of that I
got as I got older I cannae I just co2
we used to get into it you and I it was
just sports I mean and that's what no
she's boards politics do we get into a
politics dawn tube we would have our
eyebrows all the way up I thought we
were on the same page with that I think
it was mostly sports I think the one
time we got into it that's why do I
remember I hated like literally tell
myself uh-huh next time you and Brett
get going you have to be the guy that
taps out and I started tapping out and
we have we've been good ever since well
I said no it never got ugly but we would
slow it would July Unitas we both agreed
on Johnny it was something important
like that was and I think he wanted to
kill me at the time because I think I
said Elway / Brady I went I went Montana
Elway Brady and you went what I don't
know if wrong with that no at the time
you did no I did it because I remember I
hitch oh no you know what it was
something different because I was always
the guy people going like Brady's better
than Montana now once he got four rings
I said dude Montana needed four tries to
get four rings mhm
Brady needed six and then once he got
his fifth I said okay now we got his 50
but my whole my whole list has changed
now because the year that they that
Denver went is when I texted you and I
said this this year Brady we
and not that it matters said he
impressed me but I'm like this year I
was really and yeah that's what he had
to deal with and you're like yeah but it
was always over sports I mean the the
politics stuff I think we were on the
same page with a lot of it
if I can recall there was some huge
[ __ ] okay
football Auggie I can't remember all
right I didn't know yeah I forgot you
play drums too
yeah you said you'd go on your part I'm
not like you I mean I'm I used to have a
set the trap set I played for years and
then my grandmother salted but you know
every once in a while I'll go into the
Guitar Center and start you know playing
on me you got it do it but when I open
free get those [ __ ] v-drums no you
got again you get those [ __ ] things
man I'm telling you like you know if you
like when I lived in an apartment in New
York I I just put like this I forget it
was some sort of foam rubber thing down
and then I built like a little riser on
top of that and then foam rubber on that
and then I put the kit down or something
like that no wait it had to be solid so
the things would stand up I don't think
this phone run to that but I I and then
I went downstairs to the guy below me
and said hey listen I played drums as a
hobby and he's looking at me like you
[ __ ] I said no here's my phone
number I go I work at night you work
during the day yeah I go I'll only play
between 11:00 and 2:00 during the day if
for whatever reason you take a day off
you have a day off call me the second
you call me and pick up the phone say
I'm downstairs I will immediately stop I
mean how could you have a problem with
that and you know what this [ __ ]
[ __ ] did [ __ ] three months later
I'm playing like 2:00 in the afternoon
and my phone rings and I got hello and
he goes we a knock it off yeah the first
time I say hey buddy I got you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] saying that like you said it to
me 20 times go [ __ ] yourself and I hung
up I never talked to him again and he
never called again but I still only play
during the day night and I wouldn't play
weekends either you think now if he's
watching Conan or something he's like
that's that drama guy that lived
upstairs he must have switched careers
then cuz he sucked it drums he was
terrible you said you do on your uh
you're on the list podcast you do a lot
of top-10 stuff yeah we just list [ __ ] I
mean again it's it's arguing with your
friends over dumb things which is all
right one for me well let's start let's
try to get the fires going again we can
do five we can do top five I mean this
more your opinion my show you know it's
not so much me sometimes although I've
got a little hot-headed like over top
[ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] you for over rock III
you know stupid [ __ ] yeah that's
important it is very important in the
schema what matters to you your living
your truth you should start a blog about
it um I was I saying did you want to
discuss who who the top athletes Boston
athletes are of all time okay
like would you take Brady over bird do
you think he's number one and then the
next one could have been all top top
week we'd love to do ten we could I
can't get rid of Larry Larry's like in
that especially to now looking back 30
years and his stuff is still amazing and
I know Brady is gonna be amazing too
obviously but and I know he's won two
more than Larry one my thing about Larry
was if I could go back in time the
second he started to do the blacktop on
the driveway I'd be like Larry let me
let me do that let me do that there do
such like a [ __ ] I'm gonna call a guy
and cheap well the years I remember
those when you black top and driving
like that what a sucking brush they'd
give you yeah yeah that was not made for
a six foot nine six foot ten inch guy
and he black topped his own [ __ ]
driveway rather than paying somebody
that whole blue-collar I'll do this
myself
and he [ __ ] up his back Wow that's why
it was never the same after that I was
gonna say uh all right tell if we're
doing smoke coke if we're doing if we're
- yeah if we're doing Championships I
mean then yeah that you got throw Bill
Russell obviously no bill Russell's the
top yeah it would be though Russell is
to say he's got 11 right so a lot of
people leave him out i I put him in my
top five and then you got Ted Williams
and then you got Bobby Orr who totally
changed the game Bobby Orr was mine who
Wayne Gretzky says that's the yeah Wayne
Gretzky goes that's the guy so you know
what it is at this point there's so many
people in Boston now well I just love
being arrogant now and you're you don't
have to go that far back last no you
don't have no and don't and and I was
gonna say - I would put my top ten in
Boston athletes mmm because she's my he
would be your Don Mattingly was Wade
Boggs I like bugs I used to like uh ya
know and I and I might throw Andre tip
in there as well Andre tiffith although
there's a lot of great guys that never
got uh never I mean I'm a Jim Rice we
had to we had rice Fred Lynn Collier
stravsky
we just had all stravsky oh yeah all of
these great guys that you know and I I
always hated that I always make fun a
day I don't hate people like I hate Dan
Shaughnessy I just like breaking his
balls but like he wrote that book the
curse of the babe and it was just such a
cop-out where you just don't even
address granted I never read the book
but I just looked at the title and I
judge the book by its cover and it just
was such a cop-out assist I thought we
were just a really bad franchise we were
a bad franchise we were like the Flyers
where the flyers got to 1/2 cups by
beating the [ __ ] out of the league and
they were like that's what works mm-hmm
and that's what the [ __ ] we're gonna do
now they're finally coming out of it but
dude they had like a 30 40 year [ __ ]
hangover of trying to continue to make
my 30s more fair
Jerry bullies doc is [ __ ] oh it's
incredible
yeah but they was so successful winning
back-to-back you got to stand day we'll
only in the league since 67 and they won
that first cup it's they went
back-to-back 74 75 their seventh and
eighth year in the league and
everybody's like this is the future and
that almost destroyed hockey and they
just continued it was ok during the 80s
because there was still a lot of that
left but in the 90s early 80s it was
still I'm never going to Brendan Byrne
Arena and watch the Devils and flyers
going it we just went just for that for
the fights yeah dude it was it was crazy
the first like nine Bruins games I went
to I would only go if they played the
Canadians because I knew there was gonna
be a bunch of fights and there's a
classic one on YouTube where there's a
bench-clearing brawl back when the
benches faced each other the old Boston
Garden and Chris Nilan was walking off
the ice and according to him somebody
threw something at him I don't know what
happened he pushed Ken lensman and then
a little Ken lensman the rat goes down
after this heavyweight Nilan and all the
sub - there was like cops involved in
there the benches cleared and I was at
that game see that the thing with sports
to me now and again man I know the
athletes are you know better but
the no that's that's what Big Papi I
gotta put big bigger they poppies in the
10 yeah he might even be 5 that's what
we were arguing as he turned I remember
when II Ramirez no the Jerry Rice thing
that he was faster than lightning and
you were like how the [ __ ] is he faster
and I said I saw this sports that's what
it was and and yeah you can't be but it
was a sports thing that I saw but
getting back to the athletes today a
sports thing not a scientist thing it's
a sports thing like they were wizards
no but we saw ok I can't believe I
wasted a good 40 minutes of my almost a
headlining set which is technically 45
minutes 45 minutes know that I mean
there's a part of me that enjoys it
especially with people that are I mean
not when you get worked up over stupid
[ __ ] but I mean but that's just
inevitable maybe cuz the German in us
maybe that's what it is but I do like
the mental the mental chess like like
the the point four point because you
know I don't I don't really do you don't
really get that a lot
that's why I only what comics like its
regular civilians I haven't done it have
you ever done it here and you're in it
you having a great time and all of a
sudden you look around at the other
people yes I see people like walking
away are the worst laughing at you what
are they arguing but comics get it like
I don't I don't do well with civilians
that's like when we go out to dinner
with like some random couple I'm just so
[ __ ] bored man yeah about you kids oh
no ya know it when conversations on Idol
the whole night if you got a kid in a
kid playing soccer and you know we're
thinking about going to a to Mexico they
have what do you think of Trump's acacia
palsy and my wife just starts kicking me
we need something here now you can't
yeah you can't do that I start telling
you about some [ __ ] winery that you
can visit and it's good for the kids
because they have a little zoo
you can feed pigeons and there's [ __ ]
horrible I know
and then the worst and they see you and
just like I just haven't saw my face I
can't do it like I'm Nia stop doing this
to me but like there was this time every
time we would go to a [ __ ] party
afterwards on the drive home I would get
like this whole breakdown well I get I
do actually have a bit where I talk
about the report card
oh is that what yeah I need to tell you
that before we know it they all do it
you get this [ __ ] report you think
you had what is your report you know
like you think and then they break out
this [ __ ] report card and you're like
what the [ __ ]
okay usually documented here's the thing
can you [ __ ] imagine the Hellfire if
you ever did it to them oh you can't you
can't you can't it's so funny money my
wife tells me what to wear sometimes you
look why you always dress that you
always tells me you're dressed like a
bouncer they will step up your puckered
wardrobe as I'm dressed like a complete
was I was gonna wear my Adidas tracksuit
and I said if I come in with this easy
in a [ __ ] murder me no no no I'm
wearing this because I'm doing well
those all thinks comedy polka things so
I'm dressing like a [ __ ] yeah I was
bored but I had an adidas one day no um
but you know it was funny we were at
Sebastian's party remember the baby and
you were [ __ ] hammered and we were
hanging out I was 22 I went to go take a
picture I was by his pool and somebody
backed into my hand like barely touched
my hand and I dropped off full whiskey
into his [ __ ] pool I was so
embarrassed it's not dude it's fine it's
fine
was I bad hammered no it wasn't no I was
here I'm saying in a good way because we
were all we were all drinking and it
wasn't a lot of drink I was watching our
wives and they just look at us from a
distance I eat my wife's nervous I can
tell it was don't kill you having a
great time I like dude we're gonna rent
a [ __ ] yacht
radiant with all of us we made we made
we can guys it'll be 300 bucks apiece we
are in a great time we'll get the
[ __ ] in a film that will film it yeah
I'll hype you're special you want me out
we're having a great time and I'm
watching my wives and they're just
nervous they're just watching going what
the [ __ ] is gonna happen I really don't
think women get our relationships like I
find that men we I mean at least me and
my friends we bond through conflict in a
sense I get like if I know you're an
Eagles fan and you know I'm a Cowboys
fan I'm expecting you to go on your soup
you know whatever its way to say like
watching them argue on Real Housewives
but I love the drug when we act like
Real Housewives over sports for some
reason that this is the thing I've been
really I've been trying I guess the most
accurate way to describe this is I've
really been trying not to be me in my
relationship
it's so [ __ ] honest I I'm starting to
feel like that is the problem like no we
get along great but when there's when
there's work to be done in the
relationship it's it's always now bill
you're this this and this and like one
time I was hanging out with this this
we're treading on hard you know what
tread not we got to be careful with this
yeah at this party and I don't give a
[ __ ] like my wife schools she'll [ __ ]
she doesn't listen to me anyways my wife
hasn't go to a stand-up show of mine
like three [ __ ] she doesn't either
she lives with me she's my wife sick of
it yeah I mean and it's not conducive
for what I like you know for it is for
like you know that imagine having to
watch your wife talk for an hour can you
imagine - why would you do that why
would you do that - the person the same
thing uh over yeah why would you put
them through that I have to I have total
[ __ ] apathy from when it comes to that
[ __ ] I also what others might do the
dishes
what I also found to try to get
something in the good and the good side
of the ledger and the scorecard
yes something i I i found that my wife
you know when when the one thing i found
attractive about her is that she was not
laughing at some of the [ __ ] I was
saying and I'm like okay this girl's got
yeah like in my think about Robyn [ __ ]
when I was young
in style and you know cuz I was kind of
a bad kid and a bad early adult and you
know and she's like you know I I don't
find that you know I mean I get why
people think it's funny but and I'm just
like alright this for me it's a normal
bar so yeah because I grew up in so much
dysfunction you have morals yeah oh
what's this this is new laughs I grew up
in so much dysfunction that I didn't
realize I grew up in dysfunction like
you think your shits normal until you
meet normal people and then and then
you're like you're like oh you know you
have a day I would say to you you you
meet dialed down people yeah they're not
normal because eventually you just you
realize that on some level they're out
of their [ __ ] mind it's just not the
kind of out of their mind that's gonna
get you arrested
well like my nobody my wife's family
knows anybody that's been to jail and I
know like 15 people you know and tell
you we're a no circle so I don't know
but I'm saying to me and my friends you
know you think that shit's normal and
then but it's not like I've met people
so those are like the tips you're
getting like how to survive in jail as a
part of its supposed to you need two
years of a language well and a couple
extracurricular activities so you can
get into a good school though there are
people that around it people that are in
it and people that are about it I was
just around it and I kind of dipped my
toe in it and I actually again not to
preface it but I say on stage this that
I'm I'm just because I committed crimes
doesn't mean I'm a criminal and yes it
does no it doesn't Millennials [ __ ] no
it's not if you ever if you ever hang
out with a [ __ ] criminal there it's
just a whole different breed and and
when you're saying I played high school
football I'm not a football player yes
you are you're not a pro what you gotta
kill this is why we argue like yeah okay
you commit crimes you know like you know
but when you're younger it's not you're
not there's a certain type of all right
how about that I get it just be that Joe
Joe Bob you tell a joke at a [ __ ]
party does it make you a comic okay but
it makes you funny oh it worked it
worked this is this I've drawn a picture
and you want like the ain't no the draft
days for the NFL it's for the mob and
you're waiting to get that call and it's
like the 7th 8th round you just didn't
get it
you got on the tax
squad that league folded yeah you got on
the taxi squad and everything and you
would never just weren't you didn't
quite make it to the mob so you weren't
like a you weren't a career criminal but
if you I was like my wife and she's
normal and her family's okay that was
the point you're trying to turn into a
big argument okay no but I get what you
say I'm not trying to sugarcoat and it
just it is what it is
what say you Aaron what would you say is
he you because there's different levels
because there's there's a punk there's a
dirtbag and then there's a criminal and
then there's a career criminal and then
there's a psycho where would you say
he's on that spectrum it's like he was a
punk he he grew out of it you know that
was a juvenile delinquent yeah in
fairness to him he never said what he
did but I've done somebody said I
committed crimes that's beyond you know
right just stealing [ __ ] stealing like I
stole a car in middle school and then
that's a felony I know and then me and
my brother a lot of cars like you'll go
to jail for it but my my friend I just
rode shotgun and laughed off it was like
in 85 80s I tried to steal a car it was
actually a truck we tried to steal a
truck did you this what we got in it and
then we were looking for keys on the
visor we couldn't find it so then we
just pushed it down into a room now see
now that's just being dumb and you know
what I mean that's not you're not a
criminal I remember I remember we were
pushing all the wheels were like locked
and then when something snapped
and it was going I remember pushing it
and laughing so hard I couldn't feel my
legs
and we almost we were we were shit-faced
and trying to run back to the car drunk
laughing it just what you did and then I
remember we all had to get ruined some
but then we all had to get the [ __ ] out
of there god I haven't thought about
that in forever we all had to get the
[ __ ] out and I remember the next day my
buddy going I feel like we got cheated
out of that laugh because we all had to
[ __ ] just were you the funniest side
of your friend was during the day too
well I got a ride daily and you were
drunk and we were drunk was a summer or
some [ __ ] now somebody somehow that was
the winner that's that it was hot it was
the weekend and somebody somehow had got
a case of beer and you know one of the
steals you just start drinking liking
I got an idea well you know how like you
like the way you drink when you first
drink is I give me that [ __ ] about like
it's way worse to get like there's a
poisonous snake it's way worse to get
bitten by a baby one than an adult
because I don't know it'll give you just
enough to [ __ ] you up but the baby does
a baby just like both barrels that's how
you drink like when you're an adult and
you drink you're a gentleman you sip and
[ __ ] you know you're like Gleason in the
[ __ ] the hustler right but like when
you're a kid you're Fast Eddie and
you're sucking it down you're [ __ ]
mess that's the way we were drinking and
we ended up you know and we were
underage so you end up in a parking lot
over the woods now here we were in a
parking lot here's the difference to my
point now let's just say that I'm with
my friends and there's one kid that's
like hey I have an idea let's break into
this dude's apartment okay and then
you're like okay cuz it'll be fun to
break in somebody's apartment but this
guy's got other motives like he's
thinking he's like Nenana I know we're
gonna take the credit cards I'm gonna
take the keys like he's got it planned
out but I'm in it just because I think
it's fun you're in it for the story yeah
and the laugh yeah the story absolutely
you know when you're a young dude and
you're trying to get a rep you know and
you're just so that's when you commit
the crime but then there's the guy
that's like no no oh he sees a future
you see yeah and then other guys gonna
have to pay for solutely like we're
never gonna get caught that would be a
huge that would be the difference
between like cuz when my buddy pulled up
with the car I jumped in the car and we
just went cruising and we ended up
wrecking it it was four of us I would
love to tell this story one time about
that night because it was four of us me
and my well you should tell it on your
podcast you're on the list and I won't
do it now yeah is that a
passive-aggressive the [ __ ] out with the
story or is that it like oh no I cause
I'd seem like you didn't want to tell it
now if you want to tell it now I was
saying no it's not even that long I'm
just saying like if I could have a write
a short film or something oh it was just
an interesting night that the two of us
the four of us two of us got pinched the
other two didn't and they didn't rat you
out or anything no did you I'm at one
time we stole a case of beer out of out
of a [ __ ] liquor store and the whole
thing was like this was the deal so we
came up with this idea
I can't tell this story because don't
use names because we're doing we're
doing some of it on a project that I'm
working on so I can't I can't give this
away but we bucking we've given these
these people like blue ball story blue
blue balls here you know the deal is
this basically you [ __ ] walk in the
oldest guy looking kid and you just
[ __ ] you walk in you stay online you
know you act like you're gonna pay in at
the last second you [ __ ] run out and
yeah it was one of them ladies are going
to grocery stores when I mean I had no
money man and I'm like nineteen I was
washing dishes at Hooters I like three I
was bouncing at a nightclub washing
dishes at Hooters
I was trying to do something with my
life I was never have to clean the
grease trap the [ __ ] worst
we had to do it every night because
because that's not bad ours was every
three months it'll be three months
agreed to clean the [ __ ] fryers man
that was a pain in here empty all the
oil out I was a prep cook I robbed that
I robbed every place I worked for a man
that's how I ate I used to kangaroo
pouch my apron and then when I was like
prepping food I would put in my apron I
had a [ __ ] homeless maybe that's how
you ate well I was I was pretty much on
my own I mean I was I was one of those
losers that went away to Community
College
[Laughter]
that's the point I'm crashing at some
other dudes apartment and then I was
trying to go to school and just try and
get my life going man and when I worked
there I just used to stack up on food
out of cooler in the trunk oh you were
broke okay yeah but I've told this story
before I was working in this restaurant
there was this guy who worked there and
he [ __ ] he lost his license for
drinking and driving so many times that
there was no date that he was gonna get
his license back and this was the 80s
and he had lost it this is right when
Mothers Against tricking a driver came
out like he did the level of [ __ ] up you
had to be and he was about 34 35 and he
already had the gin blossom nose he
looked like he look like WC Fields yeah
and he was 34 35 right and so he used to
ride this moped to work I was living in
North Carolina and he [ __ ] used to
ride this moped to work
he lived in a trailer park so this
[ __ ] moped he didn't have a driver's
license this was it this was it for this
guy like this was his mode of [ __ ]
transportation I remember he stuck like
a nun cold winter days he'd come to work
and he would always be drunk and
hungover so he would shower late and he
would come to work and his hair would
still be wet he would have frost on his
hair he was like [ __ ] grandpa Munster
right so what time he parked it back
there this other kid whose mo he's into
Metallica classic burnout teenager he
had like that he like never shaved his
upper lip so he had that awful
prepubescent [ __ ] look like somebody
yeah it's always blonde no matter what
color you get jet black hey that little
blond mustache right so we thought it'd
be funny if we took his moped and hid
the thing and he think that it was
stolen watch him freak out and be like I
will tell you it is so just to freak
this guy out this guy had like nothing
right so he was in waiting tables and we
took his moped and behind the restaurant
was this little shed built into a hill
that we they kept all the extra kegs of
beer and all that stuff so we wheeled it
around and put it up on the roof because
you could just walk it was like a
driveway you went up and we just stuck
it up on the [ __ ] roof and just left
it there and he came out and he thought
he was [ __ ] freaking I remember
pretending to wash dishes and my
shoulders were shaking watching this guy
I mean this was like his [ __ ] Hope
Diamond and then finally we couldn't
stop and we just all started laughing
he's like you [ __ ] [ __ ] and we
got yeah that's up on the roof when we
walked out for the roof and it was gone
somebody started it's so [ __ ] awful
it's better so he reports it stolen they
ended up catching the kid like two days
later and the kid had tried to paint it
I'll never forget it was a silver one
and he's sprayed all this black on it
did a [ __ ] job and it looked like
[ __ ] [ __ ] and I remember like three
days later the guy riding back to work
with frost in his mustache and this
horrible silver and like [ __ ] up black
paint all over it I actually really felt
bad I felt bad about them do you ever
remember to keep growing up with the
mini bike that kid was always gonna
equal scumbag like he did you guys make
mini bikes I have that kid that had the
mini bike with a lawnmower I meant well
my parents were like you're not riding
those [ __ ] things they're both in the
medical field so uh one of my brothers
bought one and had it hid by was another
shed that was always a shed when I was
growing up he had it hid behind there
and just the pressure of it cuz he had
to keep it away from us and he thought I
was gonna write it yeah did he buy it
from a kid that made it or was it like a
legit oh no it was a moped it was bought
it wasn't a it wasn't a dirt bike but my
my parents were like you know in the
medical field so no matter what you
wanted to do if was remotely dangerous
my dad's thing was Christ I had a
patient in the other day riding a moped
hey bla bla bla bla he's gone he was
always dead no matter what the [ __ ] he
wanted to do he had a patient in another
day you know it's just like it was just
so [ __ ] what a coincidence Ted hmm
every [ __ ] thing I want to do is like
one of those they always play that worst
possible scenario game but here's the
thing now that I got a kid I totally get
it
I told you did they tell you that like
once you have a kid you'll understand no
you know there's no my parents what
great thing about them is they let you
figure out as much as they stayed on you
on the big [ __ ] don't do drugs and all
of that and stressed education they let
you figure out a lot of [ __ ] and I think
that that's why you know people my
family are like self-sufficient mm-hm
and have that [ __ ] you know you don't
stand around looking at the rock you
like I guess I have to push this [ __ ]
thing or it's not gonna do yeah I
remember like and like the life lessons
men would I this piece of [ __ ] pickup
truck and I bought I was my first car
and it broke down and so I got on the
pay phone so long ago this was I [ __ ]
called my mom like mom but workers in
started a little whole [ __ ] scenario
and I got to be a work of lunchy listen
the whole [ __ ] thing
wasn't saying anything and then I
finished and she goes well what would
you have me do and I was like oh [ __ ]
and I looked down there was a phone book
right there and I was you know somebody
[ __ ] ripped all the pages out I said
I guess I gotta call a tow truck
I mean she was one step away from
calling me a [ __ ] mom yeah like why are
you [ __ ] like what am i a [ __ ]
mechanic all of that was in that you
have a dime why did you [ __ ] it was a
dime back then why did you [ __ ] call
me call a [ __ ] tote what am I gonna
go down there and pick the truck up you
[ __ ] [ __ ] I know you suck at math
are you bad at life too I heard all of
that and I felt stupid
I remember I was mad at her and then but
was it tough love or was it
no it's totem bother me no no no no no
it was a hole and it was tough love
because it was just like this kids got
to learn
yeah because one of these days you're
gonna be on your own and like I saw Dana
Carvey do a hilarious bit about them
where you know his kids were calling him
up or something like that because
something wasn't working rather than
calling the landlord and I guess I guess
that's a thing with kids nowadays like
they his generation went too far over
correcting because like you know if you
watch like his comedy you know the old
guy had a game called stare at the Sun
you know like I think his was so tough
that then there was maybe like a bit of
an overcorrection but I remember when he
was doing that bit I'm not gonna try to
redo it it was [ __ ] hilarious
but it reminded me of that story and
that they can like once again how right
my mother was mm-hm being like alright
well you have a [ __ ] brain use it the
the thing that I found the difference
like the way our parents were raised and
the way they raised us mmm is like my
mom when she was younger you know you
stay outside kids played outside you
come home when the lights came on I mean
you're you're a little older than me and
where I grew up is also was a little
different to in North Jersey at the time
you know it wasn't our parents raised me
to us the same way but the outside was a
safe if that makes any sense when they
were younger it was safe but now like
come home when the lights are on you're
like okay and I'm riding by [ __ ]
crackheads and you know cuz to them they
were raised that way and then I think
our parents saw a lot of [ __ ] they
shouldn't have seen at a young age
people our age well and now they're
overprotective yeah I don't know how to
I think it out with like kids like your
kids your age I don't know eyes are
gonna be a happy medium you don't really
[ __ ] me up was you know that number to
catch a predator yeah like that's that
like makes it seem that there's a
[ __ ] creep behind every tree and I
don't know if back in the day because
back in the day you just say he's a
dirty old man stay away from them but I
think that there's a with the internet
yeah and you see the
ability for people to act on stuff and
feed [ __ ] huh and watch all this porn
and all of this type of stuff and I
think it draws these [ __ ] people well
the Internet is like one big [ __ ]
neighborhood and and and there's no
really securing I mean there [ __ ] that I
see in my feet and I'm like what the
[ __ ] oh yeah I'm kind of getting but the
thing about it is though that the
Internet is [ __ ] incredible too if
you if you try to learn [ __ ] the right
[ __ ] like dude if you want to get that
[ __ ] VIII drums if you want to learn
a bunch of [ __ ] hmm you know there's
some there's everybody there's always
somebody doing a drum cover or we'll
break down something that you can't
[ __ ] figure out and now there's like
some monster [ __ ] teachers out there
Mike Johnston
the guy take lesson with Davey which
just started doing [ __ ] and these guys
are like these guys are like legit
[ __ ] like they know what they're
doing and like so if you stay in those
areas learning how to code you're good
you're good
the Internet is it is inexact it's it's
it's just an exact replica of human
nature is that like you know first of
all the idea that we're gonna build this
information Highway we're gonna connect
people all over the world we're gonna
learn from each other and like 80% of
its poor got these [ __ ] scumbag
people and these fake articles and these
that's human nature man and it's an
exact replica I've kind of been I've
been awake I'm trying to be vice 'less
here in April like nope nope or no
cigars no booze I [ __ ] up the other
day I took a couple hits over nothing
cuz I jerked off the side yeah smoking a
cigar dude I haven't had a drink since
New Year's man oh you know what to it I
think we're going over here before
before I just saw the next podcast guy
look into here before I get out of here
I do have to address the fact that the
congratulations to the Maple Leafs you
guys finally [ __ ] showed up and
played a hell of a game but I feel good
but it's going to come out Thursday I
feel good about our chances Thursday
considering you know I just don't see us
getting 40 shots on goal I
again and losing so all we got to do is
win this next one up three games to one
but it was a phenomenal game and that
was the first game in this series that
felt like playoff hockey where both
teams were [ __ ] out there killing it
so I look forward to tonight's game for
Brett arts he's got a new series on
YouTube bread that debuts May 2nd the
Cobra Kai kid if you want to watch his
stand-up special principal's office for
free you can get it at Brett be ret
comedy calm you could also go to
Instagram and also subscribe to my
podcast at Bret comedy calm and you can
also listen to his podcast right here
and all things comedy you're on the list
podcast all right Brett thanks so much -
love you brother let me - thanks buddy